guys gerard tubb is in south shields for
us hello to you gerard so it's a move
from regulation to personal
responsibility not everyone happy though
well not everyone happy and an uneven
picture across the country of course
um the northeast has some of the highest
transmission rates for covid
it's on the most worrying statistics um
here in south shields where i'm standing
um has the highest in england we think
looking at the figures it looks like
around 300
cases per 100 000 of the population
um astonishing when you think
that we were at the beginning of this um
blocking
um preventing people from going to
countries where um whether whether cases
were
200 per um 100 000
um the councils up here have all um
seemingly issued the same statement
which has clearly come
come from somewhere central this is
quite interesting in light of those
figures just have a listen to this the
time has come
for us to learn to live safely with
covid and make sure that we continue to
do everything we can to support those in
our communities who still
feel vulnerable well living safely with
kovid
up here it can be difficult for um
some people when those figures are so
high when south shields went into
tighter restrictions last september
there were complaints in the town
from traders for example that customers
were refusing to use track and trace
that people were refusing to use masks
why obviously the reasons are complex
deprivation
is one of them where i'm standing is in
the top
at 10 um of deprivation
in england and there is some
kickback to people saying look this is
not a problem it's interesting that just
before
you cross live tours the only two people
who stopped to talk to us in the few
minutes that we were just setting up to
to do this um this broadcast were two
20-somethings who said are you from the
news team you've just come to tell lies
and spread propaganda and then walked
off so
that is the problem that authorities
here
are facing trying to persuade people to
wear masks to
to do the things that they're now or
will from next week be advised to do
rather than being compelled to do the
vaccination
rate here is slightly lower than it is
nationally
and those high cases 1300 or so per 100
000 of the population will be worrying a
lot of people